[Music]
oh yeah we should we should celebrate
happy birthday to celebrate everyone
let's get
this go get that prime cake prime day
cake please
freeze
we need to fix you because if you if
this is how you cook
we won't last up here did you order an
ice cream cake
off of amazon for prime day i'm sorry
yeah i think it takes a while to get
here that looks
horrible what is that
happy prime day oh
i'm going in yeah
it's actually not bad happy friday jeff
thank you happy prime day jeff we love
you buddy
thank you jeff you're a boy
i love you jeffrey i love you jeffrey
why'd you do it like that what
i'm trying to get all this [ __ ] up i
love you
[Laughter]
i love you jeffrey damn
damn dude relax
jeffrey i love you jeffrey happy prime
day jeff
no no no no
[Laughter]
cut me licking that floor
no that's staying in staying in
[Music]
it's kind of weird how about an ice
cream cake with actual cake in it
thank you jeffrey
it's pretty good cake actually
what's disgusting is i know we have
plenty of listeners named jeffrey
and you just gave them like free pov by
now
dude i should have put that on the only
fans i can't
you did you see how much [ __ ] grin i
made on her only fans
yeah what she said on david's vlog or
something twenty dollars
20 bucks that's it nobody bought it
no she made a million dollars in two
days
jack [ __ ] [ __ ] are we doing
what the [ __ ] are we doing yo
we're giving this up for free yeah we
need to start only or not for free but
i guess this is patreon no this is bonus
yeah this is the bonus
all yeah thanks jeffrey for the cake
thank you jeffrey happy prime day
have a prime day to everyone out there
belated to you yeah have a belated prime
day and please tell your loved ones we
say happy prime day as well
it's um i think it's our favorite
holiday now it no
yeah it is i don't do christmas anymore
neither gave everything up mother's day
[ __ ] that yeah
call me mom i said i don't i don't
recognize this holiday anymore
the only holiday is prime day yep
and um what'd you get a second vaccine
you got a second one i'm just gonna do
it again off amazon i don't just feel
they do that now yeah
huh i don't know i just i every time you
know
uh well the first time i got the vaccine
it just it just made me want to like
shop
more for some reason mm-hmm i don't know
i just got really excited
using windows oh i see yeah yeah for
sure yeah yeah
that's kind of why you know i want to
have that feeling again yeah
i think i'm going to get us another
vaccine that is that is nice
it's like my love for jeffrey grows
every time i get another jab
you know my dad got two separate
vaccines
like a different one for his first and
the second one he's like [ __ ] it i'm
just gonna
get pfizer for the second one no it does
apparently yeah
but he like didn't really know that and
then it only came out afterwards that it
actually works
he's just a psycho your dad is nuts nuts
isn't that
[ __ ] ballsy literally psycho you got
astrazeneca for the first one
no way and then you got pfizer for the
second one so your dad's been tripping
ball
yeah he's like yeah he had to get evened
out yeah why
he loves all sorts of governments right
now that ash zeniga was hitting yeah
exactly he had to even it out
cody i gotta take it i gotta straighten
out dude oh i've been having way too
much fun this past year
yeah i'm cycling like at least 60 miles
a day
[ __ ] up dude
her mom's like i don't know where this
energy came from
he took that astrazeneca and he's just
been on it he's been getting one every
week
[Laughter]
babe you want some az
i'm going to hike and take this a-z
yeah pretty wild he's a beast yeah what
else did you get on prime day
uh bag of nails to feed my nine-year-old
so i could be 25 again
nice okay this is what i got what did
you get i got it this um
yep i got this zoom in a little bit this
is what i got right here
oh oh it's like a reflex ball that like
ties to your head yep
smoking hot deal on this one too yo how
much is it
what i can't see the deal oh yeah
eight bucks wow mark down from what
60 off dude damn yeah so now i can
practice
my reflexes for the fight that you're
inevitably going to have yes
nice because everyone's boxing now
blueface started training
no way who's he going to box i don't
know ddg
ddg said he was just like gonna box
another rapper
oh yeah and he also walked out with
blueface so oh blueface is like his
friend
yeah but i can see them boxing what's
that one
yeah i got this too i think i'm going to
kick it with my mom today t-shirt
it's a toddler long sleeve but i just
you know i bought it for just cause
whenever that time
comes yeah that's what's the beauty of
prime day it's like you hop on this
stuff early
you never know when you're gonna get it
exactly or need it yeah you know
you're gonna get it it's gonna come in
two days you know when you're gonna get
or even under two days yeah see this is
what i got
what'd you get yeah nail a practice nail
hand practice nail hand
oh for painting nails no for when alina
makes you painter no i was practicing
nailing the hand down when i'm gonna
nail my own hand down
so i can rip it off properly oh i see
it's a practice
ripper yeah okay so you can become 25
again this is what i got
i got this female urine pee funnel
nice but males can use it too
it's a little urinal yes yeah you just
it's like a pocket yuri yeah
nice yeah it's like a cup that you wear
but you can it aims your piss for you
yeah if your dick's not long enough you
ever ever wanted to
my dick's so small that it just when i
piss it sprays out like a sprinkler
and so this actually all it's like a
funnel
so i can actually pee in urinals what's
that thing they use like for like
you know pastries with a rolexing bag
like a
yeah yeah yeah if you ever need an icing
bag for your piss
yeah that's what that is right there
this is what i got because i'm trying to
put on some pounds okay what'd you get
this double
this xl ground beef bucket
[Laughter]
mountain you got ground beef shipped in
the mail
interesting yeah 22 pounds of it yeah
probably lasts me a day i'm on that
popeye's diet
right right so you're just eating that
with a spoon all day yup
wow and how much was that
43 bucks yeah it's a discount though man
here's what i got what else you get i
got this um
i love to wrap both my hands around it
and swallow
funny stemless wine glass perfect for
bachelorette parties gift and grave
design
gag gift for women oh it certainly is a
gag gift
took the words out of my mouth yep got
that for kels
that's a gag gift right yeah this is
what i got what's this
after putting on pounds i need to
practice in the mirror
just super strong step stool super
strong step stool
hold up to 100 pounds that's a
lightweight foldable step stool that is
sturdy enough to support adults
and it's safe enough for kids it's also
great for posing on
this is a bodybuilder stool yeah
that's good can hold my massive weight
yeah you got that it's important
i mean when you finish all that ground
beef you need a step stool that's going
to support you
for doing that pose yeah this is what i
got
i got this french bulldog replica you
pollination wine bottle holder
set of one sorry none for you oh you
gotta you got a one-of-one
um self-portrait of you in vegas yes
yeah
rolling around like a bulldog drinking
tells me it's steve aoki
[Laughter]
[Music]
but you are really giving the only fans
content today dude i know
on your back yeah i'm two-handed yeah
i'm being a little [ __ ] today
i gotta be honest this episode is called
cody slutting out
that's the that is the craziest phrase i
think to come out of tick tock
what uh it's like then right before
she [ __ ] me out or you can slots me out
or you can slap me out
never never read that
i guess i'm alone i've definitely seen a
handful of [ __ ] me out tick tocks
these are the garden gloves that i got
no nice yeah
so you look like the villain from the
powerpuff girls
yeah i use these for
grabbing the stinger out of my
girlfriend and putting it back and
putting back on your thunderball
yeah carefully replacing your stinger
[Laughter]
i'm gonna sting that [ __ ] tonight baby
yeah
happy prime day people pull up let me
sting you